alright guys I think we've done it
we're live right now welcome welcome
back to another Saturday it's noon here
in Los Angeles and we are doing the
second the second render challenge this
week and hopefully you guys got your
assets downloaded hopefully you got your
textures all on there I don't even have
the textures on there okay like I'm just
gonna open these things and we're gonna
figure this out we got two hours to make
something awesome as you guys can see I
got a little timer this time up in the
top right here I guess yeah be like up
in here so you guys can see and follow
along it doesn't matter what program
you're in doesn't matter if you're using
semaphore D or blender or Maya or 3ds
max it doesn't matter if you're drawing
Melanie I know you always draw during
these streams I think it's awesome it
doesn't matter if you're writing a story
whatever just make sure your story
includes things from the asset pack
welcome guys
we got a a what up son dude we got Bret
driver the sign up in here my very best
friend good to see you virtually at
least man shoutouts everyone say hello
to Bret and wish him a great Saturday I
hope he's having a good day we'll be
practicing that guitar Johnny Bosworth
is here I hope you even practice in
Mario Kart and Smash Bros so alright
couple announcements first we have a
weekly challenge that is issued at the
end of these videos and I got the
winners for that challenge we're gonna
talk about those winners at the end of
this thing though I'll also issue the
next weekly challenge the discourse
server it links in the description below
and also I'm very happy to announce that
this episode is sponsored by Skillshare
today so it was actually really really
cool I think they're a perfect fit for a
sponsor for this kind of stuff and if
you guys don't know what Skillshare is
it's basically an online learning
community for creatives like your guys's
like yourselves who are looking to up
there
as many ways as possible they have like
a thousand thousands of bite size
classes super easy to get into very
accessible set for any schedule the
classes are actually like fairly short
so it doesn't matter how much time you
have you can just hop in and it doesn't
matter if you're you know want to learn
taxes one of them cooking you want to
learn art you want to learn design
whatever if you can type it into a
search bar you can you can learn it on
Skillshare
so a couple glasses for you guys there's
actually this artist Patrick Foley that
some of you actually had already
followed his tutorials he does a lot of
really cool cinema4d
and octane tutorials here this guy's
awesome like he's got this like creating
realistic french fries with you know
with actually like you got some sauce in
the mix and everything this guy's this
guy is great yeah check out check out
Patrick Foley if you guys are looking
for more cinema 4d tutorials for those
blender users out there we got you this
is a super super nice tutorial series by
this guy Brandon Hicks and he kind of
just walks you through creating a super
car modeling it in blender I know a lot
of you guys do a lot of car renders as
well so this would be a good class for
that if you're looking to model
something like this and yeah you know
Melanie I know you're in the drawing and
everything so they also have drawing
tutorials and drawing classes and if you
guys know of kim jong g the master then
he is basically or this style is
basically like the kim jong g style
which is super detailed a lot of
intricate detail like pen and ink style
drawings and basically you can again if
you guys can type it into a search bar
you can find an on Skillshare and
Skillshare as a skills remember you get
unlimited access to premium content
that's regularly updated for less than
ten bucks a month for an annual
subscription and for the first thousand
people click the link two months free of
Skillshare premium on me for you guys so
thanks for hearing me out i think it's
again awesome that they're a sponsoring
today's episode it's a perfect fit and
while we're in quarantine let's go
learn on and without further ado let's
let's hop into this render challenge
guys I'm very excited so what assets do
we have let's take a look at our assets
I hadn't even brought him in here yet
well let's do that here we're gonna
start in probably three minutes I'm
gonna queue all this up we're gonna hit
that timer and we're gonna get going
here but why let me pull these assets up
how is everybody doing you guys staying
safe are you guys staying comfortable
inside I know it is it's tough when
you're locked in the side hopefully you
guys out getting a workout on hopefully
you guys are getting your walks in and
everything I know that's been keeping me
alive and Patrick I don't know of any
Maya classes on Skillshare but I'm sure
they have them just uh click the link
down there head on over you get two
months free and you know get browsing we
got a lot of stuff okay so let's get our
assets going here
Marius Marius saw the latest Crew
episode and corridor 1/4 video as well
I'm good guys I got my water I got my
kombucha I'm gonna be doing a workout
here basically every time you guys super
chat I'm gonna do 10 frog jumps silent
frog jumps those are the hardest more on
that in a second let's get our assets
going guys render challenge assets all
right we got um geez we got a billboard
and there are just like a million
textures for this thing honestly I'm not
gonna worry about textures until I have
created my scene because you know you
don't want to waste time we only have
two hours to do what we're gonna do so
we need to be very smart with our time
so we have a billboard here it's not
oriented properly and we just stand this
thing up real quick
and I'm in cinema4d s22 very very
excited to be using as 22 I'm also in
octane version 20 20 right now it's an
unstable version so it might crash
they're releasing the stable version
very soon so we got our billboard what
else do we have guys let's go through
our assets and then let's start this
challenge hope you guys have everything
downloaded if not then there's a link in
the description of this this video over
here
alright the airplane is a 3ds max file I
cannot use that cuz I'm not in 3ds max
oversight on my part which of those 3ds
max guys and gals out there please feel
free
we got a concrete barrier this is a nice
one here very very nice I'm getting all
these models from turbosquid most of
them are free models on turbos go ahead
but if you guys just use this for
personal use only I think we'll be all
good oh we got a grenade
I believe yep this comes with some cool
textures umm concrete barrier grenade we
got a guitar here this looks like a bass
guitar almost six string bass guitar
maybe yep we got our guitar what else we
have we have a pallet
why it needs all those the janky
geometry I do not know but there's a
palette what else do we have
we got a revolver this is a nice one
right here this is a really nice model
we got the right materials on here
diffuse gloss normal specular alright
let's keep going let's keep figuring on
what we got Colton I am having a good
day man I'm having a very good day
thanks for asking
we have a shotgun with some bones I
don't know why it has bones but yeah we
got a shotgun what else do we have we
got a lot of guns ooh this is definitely
gonna be on my list this is a chimney
with no materials but I'm not gonna
worry about texture and stuff until I've
set up my scene because I don't we don't
want to waste time we only have two
precious hours okay but you know two
hours is better than one hour I'm used
to doing this in one hour and it's
difficult no matter how much time you
have cuz you're gonna use it we're gonna
telephone pole
no textures on this guy so we're gonna
have to get tricky with our texture game
or just add a whole bunch of fog we'll
see already I'm thinking telephone pole
chimney in the back I mean we can add
any stuff that's not in this pack as
long as you use mostly items from this
back like I might use some trees from
Forester or something and we got a work
light lastly boom right here and I think
there may have been like two people
models included in your guys's assets
but maybe not I can't remember I've been
messing with the links here we're gonna
get the links right for the next one I
know there's been
you guys are having some trouble
downloading this stuff but if you have
the people use them if not all good I
don't have the people so all right so
that's what we got
I'm gonna just quickly whoa hello
penguin we're going to start this this
challenge here in like two seconds
because this is about to get serious any
questions before we begin guys any
questions we got 218 people in the live
feed right now this is fantastic
and thank you guys for for let me close
steam I got so much stuff going on here
I'm gonna close this cord for now but
yeah last week's video did really well
like is the best video that since I
started this whole thing so I really
really appreciate you guys for being
there live for that and for maybe
watching it after the fact or if you're
new and are here from that video then
welcome there's gonna be a lot of fun
here Jacob can you use assets from quick
so yeah you know texture your stuff from
quick soul but the point is to make a
render with basically these models here
you know if you want to use any other
models I'm gonna say that you're have to
make it live right here don't download
quick Selassie if they are like full 3d
models okay textures are fine but as far
as models go let's use these ones here
that's part of the challenge definitely
going to use aces CG workflow in the
future it's actually really cool because
octane 2020 has an aces option which is
amazing so glad they finally implemented
that how do you use this placement
properly you have bad edges you know we
might get into that who knows we might
scorn we're doing a render challenge
today we got two hours we've got the
assets downloaded hopefully you guys
have the assets downloaded to uh if you
do have the assets downloaded give me a
thumbs up if you don't have the assets
downloaded and are still trying to just
type an X or something and we'll see how
many of you guys are ready and we will
begin the render challenge in the
meantime yeah for every super chat I am
doing ten frog jumps so you guys can
throw me off my game I challenge you to
throw me off my game
during this render challenge because I
promise you're gonna need two frog jumps
what are those it's a squat and a leap
into the air and you tuck your legs into
a ball at the top and you have to land
silently and the silent part is the
difficult part because yeah is it just
gets those quads going and we need to be
working out especially right now because
you're gonna go insane if you don't at
least at least me I'm gonna go insane if
I don't work out so that's that's my
challenge to you guys to challenge me to
do frog jumps with every super chat to
throw me off my game here but it looks
like you guys most of you guys have yeah
it looks like most of you guys have the
assets here there's some of you guys who
are still trying to get them hopefully
your download link does a thing pretty
soon
and I just want to make sure that the
stream is good for you guys
I'm getting a little warning here that's
saying it slower than usual but give me
a little happy face if the stream
quality is okay for you and we will
begin the challenge here this is gonna
be fun make sure you save your stuff
guys
save your stuff save your work you're
going to need it I promise you know
these 3d programs they crash sometimes
that's just the thing it's part of the
game all right we got mostly thumbs up
what are we supposed to do with the
render
you guys have to make a piece of art
that speaks to you in two hours that's
what you're supposed to do oh and yes
once it's done
just please upload it to the discord
server the link to the discord server is
in the description of this video put it
in the let's see I believe it's talking
about the stream channel that's where
I'm going to look at your guys's art
once you upload it at the two-hour mark
talking about the stream is where you
need to put your image
Timothy you can't think of anything to
do with the assets dude come on
I believe man I don't know what to do
with you I don't have no idea what I'm
gonna do right now all right
yes stroll along and absolutely upload
it to the discord chat please do that
alright guys fishface games missed the
beginning we're doing a render challenge
hope you got your assets downloaded we
got two hours you can see the timer up
here and yeah render time no it needs to
be posted alright two hour mark needs to
be posted to the talking about the
stream channel on the discord server in
the link below and if you guys failed to
download the assets keep trying you know
just get something in within that two
hours in it and if you can't all good
just try again next time or it doesn't
have to be live you know it's just fun
to do it together but keep working at it
let's jump in here alright the timer has
begun
all right and we're off to the races the
challenge has started what the heck do I
render here
I got a billboard that's pretty cool
concrete divider I'm down for that
I think concrete divider might make it
in to the challenge here the scaling is
way off so I'm gonna just pop in a
figure and scale this up okay what else
we got our billboard that's pretty sweet
[Music]
a grenade I don't know a guitar I don't
know
[Music]
pallets maybe maybe it's like a
industrial kind of vibe or something um
pistol these are all tiny things that
are like small details we can got okay I
could see maybe like some guns up
against like a concrete divider or
something and then in the back
definitely the chimney in the back big
fan of this guy I'm gonna just control a
everything in here alt D to close into a
folder and I'm just gonna copy this into
our comp here textures nope definitely
not big enough based off of that person
so I'm scaling from the midpoint I
definitely want to scale this from the
bottom so I'm gonna use the axis Center
tool and let's do include children use
all objects and slide the Y all the way
down to the bottom execute and that's
gonna go down there but it's not
centered because it's there's a lot of
objects and I think it's just trying to
balance out the average between all of
them so I'm just gonna roughly get that
down there that's fine I'm hitting L to
enable moving and editing the axis I'm
hit T and scale this guy up and
eventually it'll be the right size if
that's a person and this thing can be
huge
like if these are stairs right here and
that's probably the right size maybe a
little big but whatever let's keep going
what else do we need maybe some pallets
telephone pole definitely we have the
same issue here with the axis being way
off center so you could use the axis
Center tool right here Center axis too
but it looks like it's averaging out
because we have this string let's get
rid of this string I don't think we need
it
top view and this is already I'm already
wasting time here oh snap
all right we got our first super chat
that means we got ten frog jumps this
doesn't be painful all right here we go
thank you
Berk for the super chat been watching
since the muzzle flash tutorial that is
a long time so thank you for that and
yes I did know that I was in a Netflix
documentary I have not heard the end of
it they somehow filmed me while I was on
my one wheel I had no idea here we go
ten frog jumps
jeez did the timer stop no the timer
still going 155 all right so those are
those are frog domes they hurt their
painful but they're necessary whoo okay
let's keep going let's keep going so I
think the timer isn't live updating for
some reason but that's all right that's
okay we will figure things out hopefully
you guys have your own timer going all
right I'm just centering the axis there
hitting L and let's just bring it down
we'll copy this
paste this into the Renner challenge its
way tiny I'm ahead t scale it up that
seems about right
okay and no I will not make frog noises
when I do frog jumps I'm sorry alright
so what I'm thinking is a bunch of
concrete barriers in the four Oh God
jeez a bunch of concrete barriers in the
foreground scorn these are for you maybe
with some gums up against telephone
poles leading into the distance and then
the giant Jimmy in the back I can't
my quadriceps oh geez whoo I feel bad
for anyone watching this video like
after the fact like when it's not live
you know I know one dude was pissed
because I was just chewing almonds in
the mic for like four hours last week oh
my god
okay let's keep going undelete the
figure and oh my goodness you guys kill
me um just throw an octane diffuse
material on this thing okay
get rid of all this stuff octane diffuse
material trained job okay condi just
joined what what's happening good
question man so basically we're doing a
render challenge we have two hours to do
it okay and it looks like the timer is
updating we got an hour and 52 minutes
left for every super chat I'm doing ten
frog jumps to stay exercised in in shape
and clearly I'm very out of shape or no
cuz these these frog times are tough
it's my challenge to you guys to try and
throw me off my game here I can tell you
right now it's time impossible I'm gonna
get something cool rendered in two hours
after you got your render done you got
to post it to the discord server under
talking about the stream and once you do
that before the two-hour mark then I'll
go over them but let's figure this out
here what are we gonna do maybe there's
a road there's like a road with some
concrete barriers in the foreground so
I'm trying to get my camera set first
okay that's the first thing
once my cameras set then I can start
placing the objects and if we did like
plain okay and a road oh my gosh visual
Oh visual dude killing me killing oh no
oh no okay all right I got 20
I got 20 frog jumps pray for me I'll be
back you know
I dare you guys I dare you guys keep
setting up your scene keep working well
I'm doing other work back here okay 20
photos I'm not able to walk
yeah
ok oh ok guys oh my god Burke right wait
you guys are just gonna this is gonna be
so bad for literally everyone else who's
not watching this live so when when I
was uh when I was doing martial arts we
had to do 80 of those in a row for uh
brown belt conditioning oh my god oh no
guys this is my render is literally like
this is gonna be my render at this pace
here okay I got 20 more G's the
documentary was called le originals on
Netflix all right I'm gonna go pass pass
away
Oh
oh you guys please
did what another one guys please please
craters please no please
all right bro bro that's just like chill
alright there's got to be a limit yeah
there's got to be a limit like every
time it's between like every minute it's
got to be longer than a minute like it's
gonna just drastically get cut in half
I'm doing is the last time I'm doing 10
now I'm doing 5 more after that
hopefully you guys like we're 15 minutes
and I had done anything
Thank You scorn I got three for you
though thank you
alright juice box the rule has applied
now oh my god critters okay fine
all right after okay look critters I got
you I'm gonna do those in like one
minute okay and juice box I got you to
just give me like a minute where am i oh
well hopefully you guys wow you guys are
enjoying the stream in this hour and 44
timer hits an hour and 40 I got you with
30 frog jumps okay Oh 24 critters 10 for
juice box
alright let's get our camera down here
we're gonna make this a road and we're
just gonna copy some of this stuff
alright this will be a double-wide
double-wide Road that's five fingers
Liam oh boy I'm glad we had a Oh bagel
okay one more thing with the background
I've never shed tears and rendered
before this is new I just want to push
this in the background oh man so maybe
it'll be kind of hi a little higher up
so we can actually see what's going on
we can get our angle nice and nice and
right when the time comes like will walk
things in you know what I mean okay so
we want telephone wires going down the
length of this road I think one side is
fine and hopefully you guys aren't
copying me exactly hopefully you guys
coming up with your own ideas okay so
what we'll do is clone our telephone
pole okay I got two more minutes okay
now what you throw that in kelowna it'll
be a linear cloner and we'll just say
well actually we'll set this instance
mode from instance two multi instance
and then it's actually going to render a
lot faster it's not gonna tax your
system he really cranked these numbers
so I'll go like 20 maybe 100 just out
into the distance okay and right now
it's going up if I hop out of camera
view here
you can see they're getting stacked up
oh alright crews this is for you man
thank you sir
we're gonna get those telephone poles
clone into the background in just a
second here but I got 30 frog jumps I'll
be back
keep at it guys
okay quitters almost for you juice box I
got you ten here
how's everyone's render coming so far
thumbs up if you guys have a direction
on where you're going with your render
here that's the first thing he's gotta
figure out what you're doing now you
place your camera you block your scene
and once you get that you start add in
the details let's start large and they
work small all right let's just focus on
the work for like 10 or 15 minutes
mariusz yes it's okay to model things
yourself um there's no assets and no
stuff you've modeled in the past he's
gotta be right now okay our 39 but yes
it is preferred to use the models it is
more fun this way oh man I got to turn
on the air conditioning hold on can you
say D von d von hell do you want even
know what's going on right now you have
no idea
spare me please Devon
spare me just give me five minutes all
right just just give me five minutes
we're gonna 200 gone you guys is my best
friend Devon we had Devon where we had
Brett I don't know if Brett's with us
anymore
I mean like he's still alive but Devon
one of my other best friends welcome to
the stream guys say hello to Devon he
was in Carbon warfare the first one they
original the guy with the afro
Estevan Oh oh boy okay let's get a let's
get these telephones back into the
distance all right we don't want to
flying high okay we want them going down
that Z all right let's just put like 20
meters between each one you can type in
the measurement here down and it's it's
centimeters by default but if you type
in like ft for feet or M for meters
it'll convert it automatically that's
pretty cool again
oh man so we definitely want to go into
the vanishing point back there and it's
gonna lead I mean it's got a lead to the
let's see to this tower you know so
where's the tower I will just call this
tower and we'll just get it going you
know well just whoa we'll get what
happened we'll get it back there
boom so now you can't review you see how
we can't see it right it's gone but it's
actually back there
if you hit control D you'll come to your
project settings here and you right here
view clipping it's set to medium is set
to large and then you'll actually be
able to see see it back there oh sure
VDB clouds all good and yes I will
probably probably make some textures
definitely for this concrete here that's
gonna have to be a thing so these
telephone poles
let's randomize them a bit they're too
uniform so let's say this is s 22 cinema
so they've put the all of the mograph
tools here as well as the effectors and
stuff so let's just select a cloner I'm
gonna grab a random and yeah let's go
100 centimeters across the board for
position cool and then we're gonna do
rotation let's do we don't want to go
crazy with it because they are they
should be like in T pose basically lined
up you know but let's definitely offset
them like 5 degrees here and there so
they're leaning off into the distance
and let's let's actually double the
distance okay so 4,000 centimeters
oh so that's just going off into the
background let's take our camera here
let's go like 24
and yeah Photoshop I'm gonna be in
Photoshop at the end of this thing so
certainly let's set my aspect ratio and
octane if you hit this little lock
button you'll lock your scene let's just
go oh point five and I'll scale it down
just within the viewport and I want
something widescreen yeah 1280 by 720
should be good let's push this telephone
pole into the background just a bit so
we can see the top of it and I'm
actually going to let's see
positive Percy what's going on oh I am
chillin right now it was a rough start
to the stream here guys we have an hour
and a half left
let's bring the stuff this tower up a
little bit it's pretty pretty far into
the distance there so
so it is out there let's just try 4,000
well Christian once again thanks for the
kombucha appreciate you man
I got you on those frog jumps here let
me just get this tower set zero zero and
let's just line it up with camera here
and push it back let's go 1,000 meters
500 meters I heard you got a crash
George
hang in there it happens it happens
I'm gonna clone the tower as well
eylül let's see grid grid array is great
we'll just go one by one by one does
that do anything it does not let's try
two by two and we'll really separate the
distance on these let's go 300 meters
that's right hundred meters 500 meters
so we got four towers and let's set that
to multi-instance as well and let's do a
random effector as well so with the
cloner still selected we'll make a
random effector and height doesn't need
to be randomized but let's definitely
randomize the X and z position so 100
meters 100 meters
rotation certainly will go 360 on that
and let's adjust the cloner seed
or is it the random seed I believe the
random seed yep until we get something
that looks right back in the camera view
so we can see what's going on
and we might adjust this a little later
all right we got ten frog jumps for
Christian and the bucho thank you sir
oh boy it hurts
Melanie thanks for the thanks for
pointing that out that's true yes we do
have 340 people watching me suffer live
here kind of concerning but this is our
highest stream yet so congratulations
guys Cheers
marble hang in there your computer will
unfreeze hopefully hopefully cuz at the
end of the day we got to post something
right that's the most important thing
post something not nothing and yes it is
a hyper light drifter t-shirt it's like
my favorite I was actually listening to
the soundtrack right now it's switched
up to Machinarium soundtrack by Flo X
also a great soundtrack
Zulu me right right but havin getting
muscles and that's the that's the point
that's the point so we're gonna have to
fix up this tower in a minute
let's get her lighting okay let's set up
some lighting I'm definitely feeling
like well oh my Tony all right before I
puke all right I'm just gonna I'm gonna
chill for like two seconds all right and
then I got you all right I can't forget
I won't forget so what am i planning for
the final result definitely like middle
of the desert kind of vibe okay
apocalyptic middle of the desert kind of
roadside barrier some checkpoint that's
been abandoned and yes of course you can
use HDR eyes which I'll be doing so yeah
let's get the lighting down I'm gonna
just make some Sun and let's hop out of
camera view for a second actually under
option is check camera option let's
uncheck that okay so when we hop out of
camera we can still see what's going
down
but our viewer stays the same and it is
live okay so we're going to be able to
adjust the Sun position here and have it
update in the Liberia so boom
something like this and we'll rotate it
just a just a hair and we can always
tweak the Sun here
we'll get there we'll get there you just
got to keep keep working things in start
large and then get smaller and smaller
okay with your detail I'll make a floor
so basically I'm gonna spawn some like
plants and stuff and just scatter them
around the like the desert here so it'll
be some sand probably some dirt will
have a busted-up road going down this
way okay
these towers I'll probably put some in
the back over here and then I think
they'll be like something a power plant
back here so that's what I'm going for
Oh Tony I hadn't forgot about you
my stomach is recovering I don't want to
push it too hard
so I think I need to get texturing right
now so let's grab some quick sille mega
scans textures I love this site so much
they always got new cool stuff coming
out so we want concrete so we'll go
surfaces concrete damaged of course this
is looks like a really good one right
here this is damaged concrete this is
also a nice one bunker concrete a little
square though this one cracked is nice
I'm just trying to find something for
our barricade yeah ooh this could be
cool this metal edged one but this one
is nice too
Christian is right composition is key
composition is key all right I'm gonna
download this one here
let's get that and then I like that
yellow one with the yellow stripes boom
and I'm gonna just make sure my renderer
is set to octane and when I import those
textures into cinema 4d they will
automatically come in as octane
materials is everyone doing okay's their
own following along on the writer
challenge does everyone have a direction
where they're trying to go it's an hour
we have an hour and twenty two left okay
so at this point you should hopefully
have an idea of where you're going if
not that's okay though keep pushing for
it okay as long as you deliver something
in the talking about the stream channel
in the discord server the link is down
below we're good the two-hour mark
that's the cutoff okay and I'll go over
and kind of review all the art at that
point okay so what was I doing I was
getting the textures concrete textures
so that's concrete
let's get that set up real quick
mm I have to reset this up
all right so I'm just gonna start
texturing these foreground elements
first the projection is off so I'll make
a projection node I'll set that to XYZ
to uvw doesn't look good I'm gonna set
that to box still looks a little weird
hmm this is cool I'm in octane 2020
right now and they've updated a couple
things I like it a lot but this is still
the kind of buggy version so we come up
the with the legit version in a little
bit all right with the normal map for
sure
I will pipe the projection in as well
let's get the roughness in
as well as the specular
now these black-and-white maps here okay
they're coming in as color maps and
they're taking up more memory than they
need to be so if you select the black
and white maps like the specular and the
roughness set the type to float it'll
save you Ram I'm also gonna grab the
ambient occlusion and use let's see a
multiply node to combine the color and
the ambient occlusion map pipe that into
diffuse now if you adjust the gamma of
your ambient occlusion map you'll see
that it starts filling in the dark parts
the mapping is still off so I need to
figure that out
so maybe what I'll do let's see instead
of using this texture projection I'm
going to set it to mesh UV and I'm going
to actually mess with it up here in
cinema and let's just try flat and let's
offset it on the y-axis so we can see
that yellow strip that looks pretty cool
Tommo yes using the pen tablet sometimes
does slow my typing down with the right
hand just a little bit just a little bit
so I'm gonna copy this texture over to
these other barriers here okay and then
I'm just going to offset on the x-axis
just so there's a bit more randomness to
the textures here
so we're doing a render challenge Toby
we have an hour and 15 minutes left to
make a piece of art this is what I have
so far I need to keep I need to like get
moving here because yeah a little behind
okay let's um let's get our road down so
I'm gonna go to bridge and this damaged
concrete is nice too maybe we'll use
that but uh let's go to surfaces asphalt
and we have these road textures here and
I know polygon has some really nice like
whoo this is actually really good
destroyed American Road definitely let's
definitely download this
so I have an image on my Instagram that
I kind of want to match in terms of like
visual aesthetic so let's see if I can
find that real quick
it's an image of Jake in the desert in
Texas
so like this
I like this color a lot is a shot on
film I believe this is portrait 160
porks are 400 okay so this is kind of a
look I want to go forward definitely
blue sky here this gravel with the weeds
and stuff so I'm gonna grab an HDR I
think that's the very next thing I'm
going to do and then we're gonna do this
road texture going as well so I'm
actually gonna go to HDR I haven for
some free HDR eyes they're super high
quality they're all free we'll go
outdoor and this is already kind of the
vibe here in this rural landscape we
want nice blue sky with a little bit of
clouds this is actually pretty good
sunflowers one
this is great
I'm gonna go with this one here
so I'm gonna go with the 16k image here
and I'm gonna just desktop this no come
on let's get let's get smart with our
our file path is here assets boom
download that I'm also gonna download a
more like overcast one because you guys
know I'm a fan of foggy scenes so maybe
there's a more overcast kind of chill
setup maybe this one mmm
or maybe something like this
16k perfect
so in octane I'm gonna make an HDR eye
environment okay in this little texture
tag or this texture box I'm going to
load that HDR eye
you didn't know and you're not gonna see
it because we have our sunlight right so
if we turn off our sunlight we should be
able to see our HDR I just give it a
minute here this is an early version of
octane 2020 so there might be a little
bit of bugs right now let's wrap this
around something like this
and let's load our sunlight back in okay
and with the sunlight tag selected if
you click mix sky texture you're gonna
get the make the directional light of
the Sun but you'll also get the ambient
fill of the HDRI and you notice these
little fireflies right here those are no
good so we want to go octane dialogue
I'm sorry we'll go octane settings we'll
set our max samples to a thousand 16 K
is way too much and a GI clamp that's
what's gonna get rid of the fireflies
I'm just set that to 1 and it'll clean
it right up
enjoy your plant run
all right so we need to set up our road
so we have this plane here I'm gonna hop
out of camera view and I'm gonna hide
the floor for a second and we have this
strip of road we're going to load our
texture
all right so I'm just putting a new
octane glossy material drop it on the
road there and I need a railing bridge
it's not working currently so I'm just
gonna actually have to navigate so I'll
go to files and it'll open up a little
dialogue box here and I'm gonna start
dragging in these files here we'll go to
node editor and I'm actually gonna pop
this in here you see this little window
or these lines here I'm gonna drag this
up and pop it in right here so we can
see what we're doing and so that this is
saved for next time you open cinema I'm
gonna go window customization and I'm
gonna save this layout as and I
currently have a stream layout we'll
replace it and we should be good to go
so yeah let's start dragging in these
pictures we have our road ambient
occlusion bump displacement is gonna be
needed normal roughness specular all the
maps were going in and again for all
those maps that are black and white Maps
okay we're gonna make sure that we set
them to float their type I'm going to
pause the live view of for a second and
I'm just going to drop all of these maps
into their respective slots
displacement will save for last bump map
the color in the ambient occlusion map
we're gonna combine together okay so I'm
gonna grab a multiply node and we're
gonna parent we're going to pipe both
maps into texture 1 & 2 and then that
multiply goes into our diffuse so if I
were to apply the texture to that plane
for some reason it's not updating
I think it's because our floor is
blocking and our renderer is also paused
or our live viewer is paused so here we
have a road okay
very very dark for some reason I'm just
gonna let's see
camera imager I'm gonna go a double on
our exposure here and refresh the scene
and I believe we have to actually hop
into the camera to have those changes
take place I'll go back to one and
visual did i/o 20 frog jumps and my
stomach is still recovering let me get
this road set up and then I got you okay
alright so the mapping is off and the
image is pretty huh
right click to auto arrange let's start
with the mapping actually I'm gonna
click the material here and under the
plane and let's just set that to flat
reload our scene real quick
that Jack things up let's just try cubic
okay and then we're going to tile it I
believe 0.5 and 0.5
let's go point to five point two five
and we're just gonna slide it over and
we need to brighten up this road it's
very dark
all right there we go and then I'm just
gonna go into the texture here dude we
are almost we are three away from 500
live viewers this is awesome
definitely the most successful stream so
far since I've been doing this the last
three months last week's video blew up
thank you guys for doing that if you
guys are watching for the first time
from that video thank you so much
welcome we're doing a live stream render
challenge here up in the right corner we
got an hour and three minutes left to
make something awesome I'm half awesome
right now like this this definitely
needs work but I got a few tricks up my
sleeve that I think will really help
make this look nice so let me just
brighten up this road and then I got 20
frog jumps for you guys because that's
the deal I set up it's me ending this
thing you know I'm trying to work out
trying to stay healthy so let's grab a
color correction node and let's just
[Music]
let's drive with the gamma let's go 2.2
I always get it wrong let's go 0.5 okay
not bad
not bad at all and then let's um we
wanted a pipe in our displacement so
let's do that as well if we click the
material here let me go to displacement
we can add a displacement and that's
gonna give us a little dialog box here a
little displacement note okay height
okay we'll go ten centimeters is fine
mid level will set the point five and
level of detail we'll go for K for now
okay
and before we pipe that in let's just
once again go through our black and
white images and set them to float
because that's gonna save on our RAM if
you look down here it's gonna update and
we're gonna get some RAM back all right
yeah it went from four to three there
hang in guys hang in through the crashes
I believe in you okay
let's see let's see yeah okay we're
doing this displacement here let's pipe
that in Oh
hopefully doesn't destroy my system um
[Music]
let's try and let's turn check camera
back on I'm gonna zoom in here and see
if the displacement is really doing
anything so we'll take 10 centimeters
we'll go 20 centimeters and yeah you can
see it's really doing stuff there so
we'll go try 15 and hop back into camera
view it looks like a really crusty so
I'm gonna I think I'm gonna take off I'm
gonna power the specular down to zero
or I might take the index up to like
three just to see if it can have a
little bit of reflectivity here
let's see I usually go linear to point
two but I'll probably throw grade on
here real quick I shot that film
portrait 400 they actually have a
portrait 400 filter here it's a little
saturated but we can tweak colors in
Photoshop a little later right
it's been an hour already oh it's been
an hour guys whenever left and Patrick
what tips would I give to people wanting
to start in VFX I'd say find the thing
that inspires you that you think is cool
start looking up tutorials for that
blender is a free program a free 3d
program that can literally do all the
things I'm doing right now so check with
that blender is amazing and then you
have sites like HDR Haven or HDR I our
texture Haven HDR Haven model Haven now
recently they have all free high quality
assets for you to start using and
getting into Jamie this is not a four
hour stream this probably be at 3 hour
tops
alright we definitely need the side of
the road that's lacking right now so
let's push the road let's extend this
road as much as we need to back into the
distance there we definitely want some
haze so we'll get some fog here in a
second but let's definitely get we have
our floor
we'll move it down just so it's not
clipping through our road
and yes mix ammonia is it owned by Adobe
which is cool because it works with your
Adobe Cloud Creative Cloud login we need
to all right we need to focus here we
have an hour left all right we need to
get the side of the road working we need
to get these poles textured and we need
to get these chimneys textured we don't
have to be very detailed with that just
- the side of the road I think needs a
little bit of something and it needs
some bushes - so let's just go and find
some like some gravel from bridge okay
so we'll go - guys we've we've done it
we've broken the 500-person record on
the live stream congratulations you all
we're doing it we're doing it live doing
it big okay so we want ground is what we
want forest jungle other this trampled
forest path could work for us I'm gonna
do a little octane scatter over
everything fill it with bushes
de NOSSA welcome welcome despite the
12-hour difference I'm glad you made it
soil let's try soil
cracked mud ground could be nice or this
trampled sandy soil looks pretty good
let's let's download that I'm gonna go
for K on this image on this texture
rather I have a lot of things going
through my head right now guys we're
hanging in what else do we need we need
like wood for telephone pole so let's
see if there's anything that's like not
veneer we need some busted up wood board
maybe something like this let's download
that
a metal texture we might be able to make
on our own and quick sabrage is
basically a way for you to transfer your
models from mega scans to your program
of choice you have to set it up I just
updated cinema to s22 so it's not this
export button isn't working but usually
I'm gonna have to just you know change
the file path but basically you hit this
export button and it brings the texture
in to your program of choice and it's
all set up with the renderer that you
choose from bridge it is like one click
the fastest way to do stuff right now
I'm have to manually link everything but
yeah we got the wood board and I think
we'll need some like brick rough brick
for the tower itself so I'll just go
with this muddy brick maybe
I don't think really matters at this
point let's try old brick wall let's do
that I got 20 frog jumps for you guys
they're long overdue Oh
oh my god Oh all right I think I'm
officially cutting off the oh the frog
jumps right now guys I'm beat
I really appreciate the contributions
the donations please feel free to keep
them coming but I'm putting a pause all
right on the frog jumps right now maybe
at the end of the stream but my legs are
jello and my stomach is weak I don't
know how many I did but you guys
certainly help me burn some calories
keep me active during quarantine much
needed much appreciated so let's get
this frickin ground going guys um I'm
gonna make a landscape
let's check camera and I think this is
when I might have to just start freaking
cranking okay guys the commentary might
come to a slow roll here
because it's time to focus your it's
time to focus okay
very nice very nice
my computer's chugging I only got one
GTX 1070
all right wonderful
how much time is left we have 48 minutes
so I definitely wanna scatter some
bushes along the side of this thing I
don't have Forester so I said no 3d
assets they have to be built in here but
I'm I kind of want to break my own rule
and grab a plant does a plant count guys
come on let's leave it let's leave it to
the chat here can I use a freaking 3d
tumbleweed please give him a break here
but I'm leaving it to you guys thumbs up
for it's okay
thumbs down for now son stick to the
rules you know I'm gonna set a bad
example but it's just a plant you know
it's just the freaking plant
Larry nachos thank you thank you thank
you for the super chat I'm gonna take a
look at that after I'm done with mine
and we're gonna take a look at all the
awesome renders that you guys made again
you can access the discord server in the
chat below and post it in the talking
about the stream channel please all
right we gotta know we gotta get a plant
three to two here
it's like thatching grass you know it's
only need
all right if I can get a piece of grass
Patrick you can get a talk you can get a
tree go for it
I mean I thought I had forests there
that's the things I thought I had forest
her but I don't desert grass and
thatching grass
thank you guys much appreciated
and let's get our telephone wires done
up okay so I'm just gonna download this
wood and get that going
so let's see we'll do we got to be very
brief with this
so the telephone pole see that will be
would the normals are all jacked up
think you are is reversed normals yes so
we'll get that and everything else will
be metal
so we'll go select set selection and we
are running out of time here
so I got to get something delivered or
else people will chop me in the back of
the head and I will pass away okay
so I actually started in cinema 4d r10
and was in that for a couple years but
got frustrated because there weren't
enough tutorials for it it was all all
the cool stuff was for 3ds Mattox so I
switched to 3ds max and I was in 3ds for
maybe 5 or 6 years because Sam and Nico
and Freddie and Brandon were using 3ds
max so I learned a lot from them and I
learned a lot from a you know a bunch of
really nice tutorials and then recently
over the last three years I switched
back to C for D and boy I could not be
happier so I'm just gonna make a
slightly reflective black material here
and I'm just gonna start selecting some
of these wires all these wires get all
these holding down shift there's a lot
of wires to go around so I'm just gonna
select a part of every wire basically
and we're gonna grow the selection and
that's gonna get everything so I'm gonna
hit you
why repeatedly and that's gonna just get
all these wires and you're gonna see the
yellow start to grow keep hitting you
why
I'm stressed out too guys well we can do
this okay I'm gonna drop my material
onto that selection and we'll go 0.02
0.02 0.02 roughness will come up 0.1 0.2
perhaps and then let's just grab like a
metal so we'll go make a little octane
metal but let's select what is actually
metal so we definitely want these guys
I'm just selecting selecting bits of
what is actually metal and then I'm
gonna do the same trick I'm gonna hit
you why and just grow it until I have
everything I need that is metal I'm just
gonna get all this in here make sure you
don't get the wires
these little braces here these
crossbeams
I'm gonna just get all this
and I hate you why until everything I
selected um gets fully selected then
anything that is not selected that's
just gonna it's too late you know next
time maybe it's drag and drop that
material on there it's gonna be all
shiny chrome let's bring the roughness
up roughness 0.25 how about that cool
and then we'll bring the specular down
we'll go point 5 0.25 cool and we'll
turn our cloner back on and those things
are basically textured now we need to
add the brick to the towers in the back
and you know what I might not even deal
with the towers I'm gonna say that let's
do the bushes first that's first and
foremost the foreground is certainly
lacking so I might have to drag some of
those guns in all right let's grab these
weeds
all right that's variation one and we'll
bring in the rest let's just set the
textures for this
we need color don't worry about this
placement bump opacity roughness
specular let's bring those in because
this is going to be octane scattered
across the lands
cool and control shift Oh we'll merge
we'll grab a couple different variations
and one more
copy that and we'll go back to our
render challenge scene we'll paste those
37 minutes left guys and my goodness
we're almost at 600 live viewers holy
crap that is awesome this is doubled
doubled in size since last week's stream
if you guys are here from last week's
stream once again thank you that video
blew up it was super awesome I will
definitely do a series called was it
called render or reel where I'll
basically combine you know I'll have one
reference image and I will just texture
the crap out of it light it and shoot it
so that it looks perfect
just like this is a little bit of a
thing that's been that's been fun for
everybody well we'll make the render a
real thing as a thing as well but okay
let's octane scatter these across the
ground here so let's render the scene
again 36 minutes left I definitely want
to add a little bit of haze in the
background a little bit of fog okay um I
might textured those uh those towers in
the background but we'll see and maybe
have some sort of foreground material or
foreground subject up front I think that
would help
Abraham or Ibrahim no camera projection
today man so sorry maybe another time
okay so we want to octane scatter we
what do we want to octane scatter we
want to octane scatter these four things
so you drop it under the octane scatter
if you go to distribution it's saying
vertex let's set that to surface let's
turn it off just for a second when we
select what surface what surface doesn't
want to scatter across so we'll select
our landscape right drag our landscape
into surface and it's gonna make
thousand copies we'll turn it on and you
can see there's definitely copies out
there you can see them all but I think
they need to be bigger so I'm gonna take
all that I'm hit T and I'm gonna scale
these up they should be scaling
I'm a hop out of camera view go to where
they are an actual space here and make
sure oh I was in I was in polygon mode
here so you wanna make sure in object
mode and then you can scale them up and
they'll do their thing let's go back to
camera view turn the scatter back on and
you can see that they're bigger now so
we definitely want more of them so we'll
set this to like 5,000 maybe 7,500 and
they're clipping through our floor here
which is not nice so we'll get that in a
second but before we do let's take the
octane scatter okay and let's make a
random effector and I'm in s22 right now
they changed up the positioning or the
location of the effectors so basically
if you get shift C you can type in
random and you got your random your
mograph stuff all up in here your anima
fector you can find anything with ship C
so octane scatter effectors let's drop
the random effector in there parameters
rotation okay we're gonna go to town
we're gonna go 1080 so they're all gonna
spin top was randomly it's gonna fix
everything up nice and we'll go 20
degrees 20 degrees so they've tilted a
little bit and then we definitely want
to adjust scale uniform and absolute
we'll set that to 0.5 so we have some
that are taller and there are little
bigs I mean select them all on the
originals hit T and scale them down
until they look like a reasonable height
here
and we'll put a lot more let's go like
20k or at 7500
not bad not bad
all right
what next let's make sure that these
barricades are like looks like they're
clipping through the ground just a
little bit
there has been an update well there will
be very soon very very soon there will
be an update very very soon there'll be
an octane update this is octane 2020
right now and see 40s 22 I'm all updated
all right let's see
we want these towers let's get these
towers right I'm going to turn off check
camera hop out of my camera I'm gonna
start positioning these towers let's
push them back off to the side a little
bit
and then I'm gonna copy it and add
another group way back here
and randomize see I'm going to randomize
the way they are distributed I can just
rotate them honestly
that'll totally do it and then I'm just
gonna take the ones up front not super
happy with how they're positioned right
now so I'm gonna try rotating these as
well
smek particles could be cool but we only
have so much time we have 29 minutes
left to finish this bring it in a
Photoshop tweak the color and then put
it in to upload it to the discord server
so the towers in the back you need to
come down a little bit because they're
clipping to the sky and let's get some
fog going so you got to be careful with
fog because it can easily crash your
system I'm also not making use of our
road here so I can push the road off
into the distance a bit more
so for fog with octane fog I'll just uh
click little fog here you can go to
materials I'm sorry you go to objects
octane fog volume right here or you can
hit shift C and type in fog and your
octane fog will and we'll be right there
so let's zoom in and see what the fog is
doing it's this little box and what does
it look like it looks like just a black
box
right just gray fog right now so I'm
gonna pause the live viewer and I'm
gonna zoom in here and you see these
little slits right here these like
little cards right it's like a bunch of
little cards that visually displays what
our fog is looking like in our viewport
all right now this will go haywire if
you start scaling this fog volume up and
leaving the voxel size that this small
all right you need to take the voxel
size and go to 100 at least
okay now you can start opening this up
I'm gonna go to a thousand just cuz you
know you're seeing it here we don't need
to see it much more than that I'm gonna
open this up stand it up tall push it
back
give it some more depth let's stand it
up a bit more let's give it some more
depth and make it go wide if you find it
really crunching your system just set
the voxel size editor set that number as
high as you can get it so that it's
looking looking nice I'm gonna bring it
just above the road I'm gonna hop in the
camera view and let's scale this just
beyond the bounds of frame okay and
let's render it and see what it looks
like it's probably gonna be a wall of
grey in our case a wall of black that's
okay I'm Jamie you're right you can
totally do a z-depth pass in Photoshop
and make that look nice but I'm gonna go
with fog for now so we'll go medium
we'll go in here absorption and just
displacement that's new absorption and
scattering okay we have these two little
boxes and from how I understand it the
absorption this is the color it absorbs
and the scattering is the color it's
like scatters the opposite color I think
so if we made an absorption just it's
like bluish color here fog should be
blue yep and then if we made the
scattering like as blue as we can make
it it should be yellow but it looks like
it's just more blue but let's set the
density down to 1 okay and that even
that is way too much still a wall
I'm gonna go point oh one and you can
see this goes off into the background
now our color is way off so let's just
tone the saturation of this way down and
same for the scattering it doesn't need
to be that intense I'm gonna do like a
cyan kind of turquoise doing it way down
and it gives you just a little nice
little something there for a nice little
background fog
and 0.01 we can go a point
0:05 to cut that in half then I'll just
give you a nice nice background fog
and you know octane is free and blender
by the way so we got 25 minutes left
guys things to make this better
I'm always a fan of a vignette and
that's not gonna work we're gonna check
camera selected certainly oh wow that is
so cool
the highlight compression we can take up
and that'll save our sky there that's
doing a really good job that's awesome
the vignette I'll do later I'll do in
Photoshop
[Music]
hmm what else could we do to this we
have 23 minutes
we're not the render that's very very
soon and I should probably render this
but is there anything else I can do very
quickly right now I might just grab that
shotgun and pop it right in to the
foreground not even worried about the
textures alt G to group copy and paste
in our scene
the fog volume we can hide with this top
little window let's bring let's see
check camera well uncheck that will hop
out of camera view we'll bring our
shotgun into the foreground pause the
renderer for a second I keep saying
renderer pause the live viewer just for
a second and I'm moving the volume right
now let's grab the shotgun there we go
it's in the bushes
I just want to tell a little bit of
story with this image so so I definitely
need some sort of foreground element and
I'm going to take the axis Center tool
and drop it negative X let's see I feel
like sometimes it ooh
sometimes it doesn't work but that's
okay I'm gonna hit L and just do it
manually
I just want to pivot the shotgun from
the butt down here and that booty and
position it up against this barrier the
scaling looks about right
I just want to make sure it's resting
right up against that thing zoom in here
make things that make sure things are
right I think that's good enough
so I think the shotgun is gonna be just
completely dark
Domenic thank you that's definitely what
I go for with my renders I want to make
it look like a photo because I am a
photographer my Instagram is mostly
photography at this point its renders
right now because we're all inside but I
definitely want to make it look like a
photo so I'm glad you said that thanks
man
guys we're at 600 heck yeah that's
amazing that is amazing we did it
alright um I'm just gonna adjust the
shotgun very quickly here and throw the
world's crappiest texture on this thing
let's move it forward rotate it back a
little bit more all right around there
make sure it's on the ground we don't
want a floating shotgun okay let's just
put our wood texture on from the
telephone pole we'll put that on the
side this thing let's get rid of these
textures so the stock sleeve we have
what do we have here
so there's the entire Remington which if
that's just wood what would that look
like
I'm gonna select this and just make this
bit here all metal
this is so janky and so quick so that's
all gonna be metal just using the same
materials that we had the telephone pole
the barrel will also be metal so I'm
just selecting these as quickly as
possible obviously it's going through
the barricade we don't want that metal
barrel
and then I'll just make this uh is
black.here the sleeve
and I think that's good enough I think
it's time to render and we will do some
color correction in Photoshop let me see
if I can adjust the sunlight maybe just
a little bit
and maybe change out the HDRI to see
what the other one was where are you
each jar I there you are
evening road maybe this has more of a
vibe
let's turn off the Sun for a second and
rotate this around
kind of like the original
so i'ma go back
yeah this was the original vibe for sure
and I'm gonna take the fog down or let's
give the towers I'm gonna make them just
metal in the background throw some
texture on there and I'm gonna render
this thing 1280 by 720 sure we have 16
minutes left it just got real current
frame 1280 by 720 how many how many
samples do we want 1012 oh god no 1,200
will do EXR 16-bit and we'll save this
boom and render sweet alright we've done
it so we've rendered we're gonna hop
into Photoshop we have 15 minutes left
we're gonna tweak the color of this a
little bit and try and get it to match
that portrait 400 shot the the reference
shot I pulled up with our boy Jake here
in Texas we're gonna try and match the
color of this a little bit more maybe
add a little bit of a lens flare perhaps
maybe add some film grain I think you
can count on that and we're gonna upload
it to the what is it talking about the
stream channel on discord okay the link
to that is in the description below wow
this is looking nice already the the
smokestacks are definitely hovering over
the ground I'm gonna just bring those
guys down real quick
how's everybody doing you guys still
working on your render is it done is it
posted we're gonna talk about it here
we're gonna go through all the
submissions take a look Wow
hey if you guys um if you guys are
liking this feel free to give a little
thumbs up or subscribe if you aren't
that aren't already subscribed to the
channel here so that render or real
video from last week did really well I
definitely wanna do more of those so if
you guys have any ideas or an image
perhaps that you would like me to match
with a render then leave a comment down
below as well um and yeah join the
discord server hop on over maybe post
the image there we're cleaning it up a
little bit there's a lot of new people
joining the discord server it's great we
just wanna make sure things are a bit
more organized so myself and the mods
are going through and we're just gonna
make sure it's a bit more organized so
we are working on that okay but it's
awesome that you guys I need to get
rendering it's awesome that you guys are
using it and it seems like you're really
loving it I've learned a lot actually
from you guys and I've met a lot of
really cool people from the discord
servers so I think that is it's amazing
it's a blessing and I think that's the
whole point of why we're doing this is
we're trying to support each other in
our creative passions and hobbies and
hopefully turn it from a hobby into a
career right but the point is I think
just keep doing what you do because you
know why not have a career in your hobby
or your passion that's why I love my job
at corridor so much you know it pushes
me it's very fun and it allows me to do
stuff like this for you guys on the
weekends like it's very very cool so
yeah um I'm just glad you guys are
enjoying this glad you guys are down
once this is done rendering we're gonna
hop into Photoshop
and we are at 12 minutes left it's gonna
have to be the fastest Photoshop job
ever this render is taking a minute
I think 1200 frames is a bad idea so I'm
probably just gonna save this out in the
next minute or so
well pre open Photoshop I'll save a copy
in the meantime let's see in case this
crashes yeah cuz just image - it's still
rendering let's open Photoshop Jamie yes
yes Chris oh my god what an incredible
artists and I've been watching his stuff
he actually did a he did a live stream
for max on for their basically their
replacement for nab and he taught
everyone how to do a really cool rag
doll but um Jimmy what episode was that
I was looking for it because I actually
heard from you guys last week that he
did that I thought it was really cool
but yeah if you could tell me what
episode that wasn't at what point in the
video I'd love to go check that out
um cuttings worth would creating stuff
like this in unreal beat yeah would
creating stuff like this be okay an
unreal - of course I really want to get
into unreal it's free and also all the
mega scans assets are free with it as
well it's unbelievable like guys this is
the time to get learning okay
you have the ability everything is free
that's at your fingertips you know you
got your tutorials this is the time and
since you guys are especially inside -
this is Teddy hey Teddy hey what's going
on - me yeah I feel the same way I feel
exactly the same way but guys it doesn't
matter what program you're using okay
really it just matters the work that you
put in the time that you spend and are
you having fun or not that's the whole
point so David it's all good man I think
the Sun Direction was good and Hari 2:40
from India that's awesome all right I'm
gonna I'm just gonna save this one more
time
and we'll go into Photoshop and we'll
bring that in okay let's see
so there's this bar down the bottom I
gotta get rid of that I feel like they
when you save images they should get rid
of that you know so I'm gonna grab the
rectangular marquee tool we have nine
minutes basically I select that I'm
gonna hit shift backspace and you get
this little dialog box
content-aware will just take care of
that it's like magic in the corner here
we can content-aware this a bit more or
I think just the clone stamp tool will
do the job so I'll select this little
bit here and just make sure pasady is up
hardness can go up and I'm gonna just
get that right there
boom okay let's control-shift a will get
us to the camera raw settings here so or
it should control shift a oh I think I
need to make it a 16-bit image first
we'll merge it explosion gamma that's
okay ctrl shift a will get us to Camera
Raw that's right do my little photo
editing and whatnot so let's see the
shadow on this definitely want to come
up or rather let's bring our blacks up
shadows up and vibrance okay let's bring
up this image here up Jake the
brightness needs to come up okay
so I'd shoot we're running out of time
we are running out of time guys contrast
will come up
highlights come up we'll bring the
whites down
vibrance will come up the greens are a
little intense so I'm gonna bring those
down maybe the yellows let's see I think
contrast certainly maybe exposure down a
little bit more and we'll just go a
little bit of curvy action on this let's
do we have six minutes
shoot shadows will go greenish just a
little bit and then I'm gonna start my
head okay
I want to add a few FEX materials let's
go overlay I want to add some film green
on this okay let's just drag that over
scale it down boom set this to overlay
that's gonna get give it a nice little
bit of texture
we can't zoom in too far because we
didn't render this with a bunch of
samples um what else what else what else
going back in control shift a effects I
want some been getting we'll take the
highlights up feather come up a little
bit and we'll expand to the midpoint a
little further out further down a bit
more
very nice and then I'm gonna give it a
little bit of blur because it's very
very sharp Gaussian blur
we'll go one 0.25 perhaps sounds good
and four minutes left I'm gonna file
open gorilla green light leaks see what
they got
something subtle
maybe like this drag this in
and we'll set this to overlay as well
okay zoom out
running out of time guys three minutes
left this is obviously way too intense
we'll go soft light and I'm going to
control you to hue shift this
hmm that's pretty cool
all right I'm gonna save it it's time
guys JPEG will do render final and I'm
going to open up discord
and drop it in the appropriate folder
talking about the stream we got a whole
bunch of awesome submissions here oh my
goodness you guys with the town heck
yeah
all right where's my image how much time
of a minute okay let's get this in here
let's deliver this
all right we're gonna close this little
mod chat window um I think we're good
cool talking about the stream look at
all this this is great let's drop this
in before I get disqualified here where
the heck of my brain guys what happened
to my brain tutorials here we go these
things are coming in by the minute
BAM it's in we've done it ah sweet we
got submissions coming in like crazy so
I'm gonna let you guys finish your
submissions here we got one minute left
I'm gonna just take a second to breathe
geez
these are so good these are also good
William all right if your blenders about
to crash print screen all right just
copy what you see on your screen
bring it into Photoshop it doesn't
matter you have 30 seconds oh my
goodness Melanie thank you so much
that's so kind of you okay let me get
gilbert thank you for the kombucha of
the cat treats thank you for the super
chat that was amazing
Melanie I hope you posted your drawing
in the in the the discord here let me
let me grab Gilbert I think he's in the
room up your back
that's it guys this is Gilbert he was
just napping just now he was chilling
he says hello and hopefully he'll stick
around Patrick oh dude yes that's great
I'm so excited to look at all these
vendors guys they're coming in like
crazy so um let's take a look at these
renders okay and then we're gonna look
at the weekly challenge winners because
every week I host a weekly challenge
where I show you guys a challenge and
you work on it throughout the week and
you post it on the discord server in the
weekly challenge channel here right and
last week's challenge was basically
based off of last week's stream which
was a render or real so people were
challenged to render something based off
of a close-up image right so I'm gonna
dish out the next challenge
right after we just take a look at some
of your guys's art I think it's
incredible we'll talk about it a little
bit we'll announce the winners from last
week's stream will also announce the new
challenge for this week so let's just
start going through some of these like
man there's a lot there's a lot Wow
I'm have a hard time guys getting
through all this so since there's so
much I'm gonna just pull up the ones
that I think we need to talk about but
I'll definitely feature all this stuff
Jonathan great work nice and simple got
your grenade on a billboard this is cool
I like the angle here of this is very
very nice very Silent Hill gotta love
the fog how this is great yeah gotta
love the fog got the Billboard in there
grenade oh this is cool
well a grenade fallen from the tower
that's awesome nice little URI as well
this is great
yeah scattering some grass around this
terrain with some trees and you know I
realized I didn't have power lines I
didn't have power lines on mine oh man
this is crazy
very very scary I wouldn't want to be
there this is a yep another scary
situation cool I like K X and G tsommo
went with the guitar very nice oh dude
this is my favorite so far cram ganyan
Graham Canyon
this is definitely my favorite by far
you got me here on the fog your
composition is incredible I think you
could crunch the contrasts a little bit
more but boy this is awesome great work
ooh this is nice and vibrant love it
love it I love the fog so good I feel
like you didn't need the pistol though
feel like you didn't need a pistol oh
maybe you could a scoot could have
scooted this telephone pole in just a
bit but I really like this mr. M good
job wow this is cool great work
man those awesome it was very scary this
looks like a album art big fan big fan
Ramy good job holy crap dude that's
awesome
what the heck chains stuned great work
holy geez man good stuff visual what the
heck dude this is so good this is so
good what geez man my render sucks oh
man this is cool this is cool
good work guys
ice cream paint job great work on your
close-up this is nice man but really
with the bull look at this you can see
you could see the polygons on this man
yellow subdivision surface on there
ludes ah thank you for the super chat my
friend
um you been doing more photography I
think that's awesome and Louisa Louisa
thank you you knew I was gonna get it
wrong thanks for the super shot good
luck with your photography as well dude
this looks like an old video game I love
this this is super creepy down yep
interesting like a little ramp like a
GTA ramp or something this reminds me of
pub G so I don't know your focus is that
where's your focus at you know it's like
am I looking at I feel like if you were
to put like a little sniper scope image
on top of this it make more sense but I
get vibes I get vibes for sure this
one's cool oh yeah very cool I like this
a lot
good work Moe's new to blender retro C
is new to blender a little janky but hey
great work you did something you turned
it in this looks like a plane crash very
oh wow
that's intense another plane crash
brutal
little gunblast sweet
ha
oh this is great this is a TTT episode
that we did that we did on node that's
awesome dude
loved the cartoon explosion good stuff
these are incredible core band tanky
great work this is all sick diggin it
wow this is awesome definitely a people
style render Marius Marius assist assess
SSS 2007 good work it was your first
render congratulations you did it okay
you did it that is the point look at
these meat guns what the heck I like it
though well what is this a plane did you
do a plane with a image on it that's
hilarious just scale it up a little bit
more that's so funny
heck yeah guys I like this a lot this is
really nice composition great work great
work everybody so many images to go
through I can't do them all but these
are great Patrick went with the freaking
drawing dude yes
it's hilarious
it's like right out just in case you
didn't know the sunset is right there
that's so funny
this is cool very creepy
so good guys so good
cosmos ICU this is awesome
love the Japanese style
dang great work guys great work guys
this is awesome what the heck man Wow
really nice oh wow
also really really nice great work you
guys are killing me this is all really
good and that's it for now I can check
back in a second but um I want to
congratulate everyone for participating
and I really appreciate all the support
I think this is really cool it's really
fun we'll definitely do this again I
think you guys seem to like this stuff
leave me a comment down below if you
guys enjoy it you guys want more of this
but let's announce real quick the
winners of last week's challenge it was
a render or real and everyone was
challenged by rendering a picture like a
close-up picture of something so let's
announce those winners real quick and
then issue out this week's weekly
challenge for you guys
okay
let's get to these winners and this one
was really difficult it's always
difficult it gets more difficult because
there's so many good renders and I have
to pick five it's tough so let's let's
pull these guys up here
all right
all right so in no particular order we
got some winners all right we got five
it was very difficult
so the first winner of two days last
week's live stream first up we got this
image right here okay this is a crazy
image of a freaking peanut M&M my
goodness this is done by ice cream paint
job I don't know if he took the picture
and this is not the render this is the
reference now get ready because this is
the render isn't that insane that's the
reference that's the render render
reference like what
ice cream paint job great work look at
the detail in this man I'm blown away
you did such a good job congratulations
for winning the weekly contest next up
we get Fish Face
games here's the reference image all
right let's close all this this is the
reference image okay
it's a faucet there was actually three
faucet what do you call them entries
three faucet entries this one was this
they were all incredible I got to be
honest they were all incredible this one
though I think had to take the cake
because this render is just beautiful
you got the grime under here
you got a fingerprint on here
you got grain in here like this is so
close to the original like your color
temperature is a little off for sure so
you could work on that but that's very
easy the shape of the faucet is a little
off as well so that's definitely another
thing that you could work on them but I
think oh no great work you got the text
down here I thought this was the
reference image at first like goodness
so good so so good all right once again
in no particular order we got vice
president this is the reference image
all right lots of pixels here a whole
lot of pixels this is the reference and
the render boom right here so similar
and again the point of this thing was to
render something and make it look as
close to the original reference as
possible and vice vide president or is
it vice president or vice president I
mean make sure I got that right
oh man vice president
yeah vice president J dizzle
vice president J dizzle congratulations
cuz boy is this really nice look at that
quality is incredible great work so the
mapping is off a little bit here that's
okay though
you have some duplicate textures here
but that's okay though you did a really
good job man congratulations this is
really really close yeah very hard to
tell the difference
vice president J dizzle congratulations
because you got the competition winner
the challenge winner
what do you even call it roll it's got a
little trophy next to it too it's
awesome
congratulations on that gratulations for
winning next up second to last year we
have timotheus with a very creepy
reference and your render is incredible
great work here super super creepy and I
was glad that you came back and with the
hand-painted version because the
projection mapping version I don't think
I could have let that fly man this is
cheating but you did a really good job
here I think you could have found maybe
a slightly higher res texture for the
tree but stood is super creepy and the
colors matched perfectly this one might
be a little more on the magenta side but
boy did you do a really really good job
Timothy is 25 congratulations you got
the challenge winner roll for this week
as well and last but not least I had to
choose I have two others here that just
did so well
but I'm gonna have to choose teyla this
is the reference and the render is
beautiful the detail in this texture is
incredible I think you did a fantastic
job I just think it's a little bright
okay I think you could have gotten the
the brightness just a little bit better
and maybe had an area light a little
behind the pencils but all in all man
teyla congratulations you get the
challenge of winter roll for this week
as well and I believe that's it that's
one two three four five congratulations
to those winners I just want to say
quick runners up this is the render here
infamous floof compared to the reference
image this is the render this is the
reference image this is really freakin
close man really good good job and very
very very very close is this other one
top snort cocaine what a rough name but
congratulations on your on your render
here you were so close
but look at that look at this here the
surface imperfection it's really nice
really really really nice in the
reference but the render it just doesn't
quite cut it but boy your clothes your
lighting was very very nice the color
was very very nicely a really good job
of matching that but maybe this this
next challenge you're so close
Devon dude it's so good to see you in
the chat here it makes me happy that's
awesome
alright so what's this next week's
challenge gonna be
I gotta be honest with you I don't know
but we're gonna figure it out right now
because I'm very very lucky to have a
couple moderators that that help me out
with this sometimes when I when I got no
ideas who do I turn to so let me check
let me check something real quick here
and see we got a little ideas challenge
ideas chat down here let's see here
hmm fire explosion Neo Tokyo car Ches
scary autumn oh these are all good bird
insects coin skeleton hmm this is kind
of like inktober a little bit you know
ooh cartoon character that sounds like
fun
okay let's do a cartoon character um
let's do let's do spongebob for this
week's challenge
you need to model texture light and
render spongebob okay that is your
challenge I'm a huge fan of Spongebob
one of my favorite cartoons still funny
to this day so yeah if you guys have any
questions on the weekly challenge for
this week's challenge of Spongebob
modeling texturing lighting rendering
spongebob asked him here okay because
I'll be here for the next five minutes
answering guys's questions and I am
currently reading this chat like so row
right now so for spongebob let's see if
he's in a T pose that's fine but bonus
points if he's actually like doing
something like cooking a krabby patty or
something
doesn't have to be crazy you know it
could could be SpongeBob's super
realistic it could be spongebob cartoony
it could be spongebob rendered however
you want it just has to be spongebob he
has to be in the image he has to be the
focus of the image and I think that's it
oh and Lassa let me know about that a
rocket lasso episode I didn't see your
your response if you did respond to that
yeah the most realistic looking
spongebob of all time would be super
hilarious so you have until Saturday
8:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time okay and
you have to deliver them in the discord
server in the weekly challenge Channel
okay the weekly challenge Channel I'm
gonna if you're part of the discord
server I'll make sure to mention
everybody and tell them hey go here and
yeah it has to be Saturday next Saturday
by 8 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
spongebob type the rules out um yeah you
can make a stylized version for sure
any other questions guys does it have to
be sponge about the character or
something from the show a spongebob
character yeah spongebob character for
sure definitely definitely I think
that's it I think that's everything
and if you guys haven't already I know I
said at the beginning of this episode
but do check out Skillshare click that
link it's in the description of this
video it's also a pin comment they're
super cool they have a bunch of great
tutorials so in the meantime you can
check out Skillshare and let me know
what you guys think does I'm going
through some like investment ones taxes
finance ones right now yeah but you can
basically find anything there but oh I
think that's it guys
William yes I stream every Saturday at
noon pacific standard time I'm in Los
Angeles stream at noon on Saturday
Chris thank you man thank you for the
super chat much appreciated get to a man
get to that sponge make it creepy I look
forward to it lucky number 13 what the
heck is this vid this this vid is a
livestream we're at the end of it right
now
we just finished a render we did it live
we had two hours to do it
it was really fun I'll show you what I
did and if you're part of the discord
server you can see everyone else's work
as well we all did one together this was
the second one we did and it was very
fun let me see if I can find you the
image we made live today did this guy
right here in cinema 4d octane was a
good time
in a render challenge what is that it's
basically I provided all the assets and
we had to make something with those
assets so everything you see in this
image was provided - the plants yeah
yeah good times I think that's it guys I
think I said I'm gonna dip out of here
eat lunch but you guys stay safe stay
active all right go for a walk don't go
crazy stay healthy and I'll see you guys
on the discord server throughout the
week good luck guys peace